i think this is one of the multi-billion
dollar trends that like you could be on
right now and i don't say that for
hyperbole like literally this is the
window the tech is just now finally good
enough it's not quite there but you need
to start now and you can disrupt all of
these marketplaces
[Music]
all right uh i went out with uh hassan
last night for dinner can i tell you
about it really quick
do it
it was awesome so
he like admires you a lot do you know
that
i admire him a lot
so uh
you pronounce his name minhaj or minaj
minhaj right i think
i think his name
is actually pronounced hassan minhaj and
everybody calls him
hassan minaj because it sounds awesome
and it's like nicki minaj
and so you know whatever i i don't know
what the i don't know how strict he is
on that well we so basically the story
of this is sean interviewed him uh
last year i thought i saw him on the
street and i ran up and like went and
said hey and it actually wasn't him and
i looked like an idiot and i tweeted
about it and he texts me i guess he got
my number from you and he texts me and
we went and hung out so this guy's like
this you know pretty big deal comedian
he is so smart he's so much smarter than
i am and that's what i i learned that
and number two i was so
intimidated to be around him because i
didn't know if like if i i was like can
i make him laugh if i can make him laugh
i'm like this is a weird and i i really
didn't i didn't make him laugh
i failed i i did not i could not make
him laugh and
he like showed me these books that he's
reading and i wanted to google like
i wanted to tweet this out but i was too
embarrassed so maybe you could tell me
but i like like googled like books on
how to be funny because after i hung out
after i hung out with him i was like
dude this guy's got me in a trance he
could tell me about anything he's so
funny and good at storytelling like i'm
so into it and i was like i wanna
figure out how to be funny and i went on
amazon and i googled like how to be
funny or like how to be clever and do
you remember years ago when i wrote that
article about this guy who games the
amazon kindle system to rank really high
and it's like [__] books but he like
buys reviews
dudes like six of the top ten on page
one were all him
it's all this guy i know the author i
don't think i saved so it's all [__]
what is there are there good books that
i can read you think on how to be funny
or how to be clever like i felt like
such a nerd like i was going to tweet
this out but i'm going to look like the
biggest virgin on earth just like how do
i like be clever in a conversation
yeah i don't know dude that i feel like
this is a um
it's like a tr it's like a skill that's
only passed down like you know by hand
and you can it's only like trial by fire
like you have to like learn this when
you're 12
and get good at like busting people's
balls and like saying the funny thing in
class um like
theo vaughn has this like hilarious i
know you like the o2 so here's this
hilarious story he tells he goes
dude i was in my like freshman i
remember the first time i realized i was
funny as a comedian he's like i was my
freshman year at college
and i was going to school in louisiana
or whatever he's like and my professor
said to our class he was like you know
look to your left look to your right you
know statistics will say that uh you
know one one of the one of the three of
you
one out of every three people are going
to end up being like a child uh whatever
molester or something like that he goes
and i stood up and i just go not it
killed and then he's like he's like that
was the moment
and first of all this is a hilarious
story and secondly uh i think there's
some truth to like you have these little
moments where you get rewarded for being
funny early on in life and you're like
oh more that more of that all right how
do i get more that laughs
i want more of that and then you just
keep doing it talent's real but i think
it's a i think just like anything like
you know some people will never be able
to dunk but you definitely can improve
you can learn how to dribble better than
before for sure like there's got to be a
skill there's definitely a skill here uh
you know i think like the best are
definitely just born better but i can be
good i can be good at it there's a
youtube video that you should watch so
i've gone down this rabbit hole probably
also after i met uh and i was like [__]
he would tell me a story on the pod
where he'd be talking and i'm so
into the story i'm like you know he was
eating out the palm of his hand
and then he would ask me a question
mid-story and i just i'm like nodding
like i'm still listening like it's a tv
show
and then i didn't realize that he said
something to me like he said he was
telling some stories like everybody's
got that kid growing up like you had
that kid who who was it for you
and i was so in like enthralled by the
story that i was just like yes
and i realized that i was like oh he
asked me for a name and then i thought
about who that would be because i said
now it said yes that there is a kid and
he's like who was it and i was like
i can't remember any names growing up
i'm so into you that i've like forgotten
who i am and my entire past and so you
know that was what was happening when he
was telling stories but he i asked him
afterwards
and i think he gave me a youtube video
that was fun that he that he's like this
is kind of interesting um so it's called
mark normand how to write a joke and i
think it's like an hour-long podcast so
it's the the thing is called writing a
joke with mark norman and mark norman is
a good joke writer he's a funny comedian
yeah he's great
and this one hour thing he like kind of
breaks down some of the
the like mechanics of what makes
something funny and it's not like follow
this
these three easy steps and you too could
be funny but it is like
oh okay i can see how this like if i
const if i consistently practice these
mechanics i can take something that's
like not so funny and make it funnier
repeatedly and then like from there
there's more the storytelling and the
setups and there's like tagging jokes
and there's other like things that you
got to learn obviously if you want to do
this well but i think that video is
pretty good
there's these guys who have this youtube
channel called charisma on command and
it's a beautiful name they've been doing
it forever have you seen these guys
yeah i remember for like maybe five
seven years ago i was yeah watching
those videos yeah and they're cool there
it could be a little lame because it's a
it's a little bit more on like
nerdy guys how to meet women which is
cool and fine whatever but like you know
i was not trying to i was dating my wife
at the time so i was like well i just
want to learn how to be like more
charismatic and i remember their name
and they like taught a course on it and
like they had all this stuff like that's
a beautiful name charisma on command
i'll watch that mark norman joke but
anyway i hung out with this dude last
night it was dope he paid for dinner so
good first date
uh it was awesome
did you try to pay did you do the thing
no for sure well not me
but i you know what's funny is when i go
to he like liked this we went to
gramercy tavern and he likes that place
which is i guess it's like a fancy or
kind of fancy place and i was like dude
you come here a lot he goes yeah i love
it i go i'm not even going to look at a
menu whatever you want to order for me
just you just do it all and that's
that's how i love i love going to
restaurants like that i do that all the
time i'm like i don't care i eat meat
and vegetables get whatever
so
the best is then after they order then
you complain uh you gotta do that that's
the the true
debug move by the way you know one thing
people liked from the last pod or maybe
a couple months ago i got a bunch of dms
about this they were like
dude i love the homie move that you said
i was like i don't remember what he's
talking about he's like he's like
remember the homie move that's like one
of the top 10 things you've shared on
the pod which was you were like dude
guess how many blah blah blah
and like when you say that obviously
it's something impressive but i kind of
guessed low so that you can have your
your punch line where you're like a
hundred million and i'm like oh i only
said ten because i kind of knew it's
more than ten but let me give you this
moment people love that uh that's
hilarious
yeah i saw the comments people did dig
that on youtube
uh right
so i made a little vow to
uh myself to bring more specific ideas
and stories uh to the pod because i
personally love the free flowing just
like whatever wherever our conversation
goes it goes
but i want to make sure that
you know we have the entree
not just
tapas it's not just the appetizers i
want to have the entrees so let's jump
into a couple ideas here i got a few too
or i got one big one
i'm gonna go one and then you go one all
right so
we've talked about this a little bit in
the past
dolly and like how much ai is advancing
and i don't know if it's just like my
tick tock feed keeps feeding me these
but every day i see a new incredible
thing
that ai can do you have to explain it
what's that you have to explain what
dolly is
oh dolly is a program it's a artificial
intelligence program um dolly 2 i think
is the current name of it that basically
you just type in any
word and it generates
images on that so you could be like
sampar
you know um
phishing and it will just
generate images that like look like
they're either hand drawn or like a
stock photo that are sampar phishing
even though no such image exists let's
say it will create the image so it like
flips the whole idea of like creating
art or
taking photos or or painting something
and it kind of like flips it on sets
like no computers and robots can now do
that
almost as good if not in some cases
better than what would be you know the
real thing or humans human stuff and so
you see that you see deep fakes like
there's videos where you'll see the mona
lisa and then they're like watch this
and they push a button and also the mona
lisa starts turning her head and she
starts rapping like you know notorious
big and it looks like the mouth is like
in sync with the lyrics and the thing
looks real it's like yeah they just took
they can take an image and they could
turn it into a video using ai like ai
can basically say oh if i have this
image i know where the eyes and those
lips are i have been trained on what
talking looks like what singing looks
like what looking around and acting
natural looks like and i can turn any
image into that and it's really good
it's really good they could take barack
obama and they can make him like this
happen now with the ukraine thing they
took the the russian president like the
way that people can photoshop an image
to make it look real
um you could take barack obama and you
can make it sound and look like he is
saying something you know completely
racist or whatever so yeah i think oh
man i can't trust videos well i heard a
podcast about that particular one i
think someone made one of these things
to show how amazing it is and then they
also show but here's the downfall and
they made obama i think he said the n
word or something like crazy like not
cool and they're like he said that and
that amazing obviously he didn't but
like it seems exactly like he said it
this is where it's gonna get it's gonna
get dangerous
totally um and let me uh so so i'll just
keep going with some random examples so
there's another one where you you can
draw like a very basic smiley face on uh
on your ipad on this app called
procreate um
and then you can it's basically just
like eyes nose mouth and you're just
like pencil drawing it then you change
the brush to the ai paintbrush
and you just kind of like shade in like
you know like in a kid we're like i saw
the wind a shape
and it like
colors in as if you like painted this in
fine detail with the shadows and the
colors the and all you're doing is
literally just moving your hand like a
fool and it's like it knows already what
like high quality art looks like and it
just turns your crappy art into high
quality art um
it's amazing and so every day there's
all these little amazing magic tricks
and they're not like
foolproof yet but the demo is getting
ridiculously impressive and so i used to
come up with a logo for a business i'm
thinking about starting i use it to come
up with a logo and it was awesome
oh i do that all the time yeah if you
just google ai logo generator or brand
generator there's like four websites
that you can use and you just say like
uh i you know it's a legal
legal startup uh the mood is serious but
still sophisticated go and it'll spit
out like an infinite number of logo
variations that you could then and you
could be like cool print this on
business cards that's like how they make
money is like print this on a business
card or like give me the i did any photo
you actually used like i used it i used
it yeah normally what i do is i go to 99
designs and i have like you 99 designs
is amazing because you can get like 30
graphic designers to like make up a
landing page and you'd be like i like
details from number one number eight
number fourteen and then someone
combines all of them and they give me
the one that i want whereas when you
work with just one designer you gotta
like a kind of be nice to them and be
like no this this is you know this is
okay but can you kind of change it like
this instead i could be like no this
sucks do this but also b you can see all
different combinations and with dolly
i'm excited to use it in that way
and so let me give you like um
a couple ideas that i've had based off
of what i've seen so here's what i i
think these can be very big ideas now
the problem with these i'll tell the
problem also um is that i think it's so
easy to do that you're gonna have a
bunch of competition um so you know you
have to find a way to be defensive but
okay here we go four ideas that you can
do with ai like right now okay so number
one
is
um
uh which one i want to start with okay
so number one is going to be
fake speech
so i'm investing in this company called
unreal speech
uh i don't know if you've heard this but
check this out this guy sends me
fake uh deep fake audio
of somebody of gary vee and jordan
peterson reading the milk roads i'm
gonna just play one of these i think you
can hear it let me just is the milk road
the newsletter that brings you so much
entertainment news and laughs it should
be illegal
y'all know hypothetically speaking of
course
here's what's happening around crypto
dude it sounds right so that's like
jordan peterson it's just like jordan
pearson here's garyvee
the newsletter that brings you so much
entertainment news and laughs it should
be illegal
yeah no hypothetically speaking of
course you can see it messes up
sometimes what's happening around crypto
the new stable coin on the block
so so you guys that's amazing that is so
good this is that available very little
there's very little training data
um
and literally just like takes my thing
and you can see the the places where my
my written stuff is like kind of like
casual i'm like you know blah blah blah
like it doesn't do that part very well
but the other parts it does like pretty
dang well for a very small amount of
training unreal speech is it available
to everyone
yeah so well it's like it's like brand
new so um
and so he was like hey sean you want to
never do an ad read again
he's like you know you have
hundreds of hours of audio of you and
sam's voice that's on the podcast like
all you need to do is just say the word
and i can make it so that you'll never
have to do an ad read again did he do it
i can make you i can make it so that the
milk road it'll auto add a companion
audio like if somebody wants to listen
to the news that are on the go like
it'll do it in your voice
um like i can just do that now and i was
like wow this is incredible he's like
yeah and the way we're doing it is
cheaper faster and like more accurate
than like the the kind of the other
models that are out there on like amazon
or whatever um so it's like you know
dramatically cheaper to do because this
is a little bit expensive whenever you
do this because it's like machine
learning but the cost just keeps falling
every year and then there's techniques
to make it even smaller and so think
about this like
uh language translation so for example
there's a world where
we do this podcast and unreal speech
could translate this into another
language in our voices with our tones
right but just speak in another language
and so now all of a sudden our podcast
is in you know is being you know done in
spanish and in french and all these
other languages and so we could grow
without having to actually do extra work
ourselves damn dude that's crazy
all ad reads stuff like that so i think
that's a that's a great business there's
also um
yeah there's there's other kind of like
use cases for it but i'll i'll leave it
at that okay here's another one
student essays
so
i told you about that guy who made a
thing called writelikeshawn.com and it
like
i like mentioned it in my email and it
like blew up it like caused him to have
like a thousand dollar bill in his
servers and he was like you know oh [__]
like you know the side project now is
like a financial burden for me um but
basically this guy trained ai to write
like i do and it was pretty damn good
and i shared an example last time
but this is not like has nothing to do
with me it's just you could take any
corpus of text data in this case he just
used my twitter feed as like the corpus
of text it could train it to write like
that well there's
one of the big things that uh you know i
don't remember growing up but like you
get assigned you have to write an essay
in school
and
you know some people would pay other
people to do it for them some people
would go find one online and try to
plagiarize it
well this is going to basically screw
that whole thing up because i'm gonna be
able to go on there and say hey
write an essay about world war ii and
germany's role in it um
in the sophistication of a tenth grader
and it's just going to spit out a full
essay or like a thousand versions of an
essay and i could just pick the one i
like and i could just edit it in like
maybe five minutes to like get rid of
any like crappy computer mess-ups dude
this is nice and uh
you remember turn it into a little bit
did you have turnitin.com like it would
help you like if you submitted it when
you have to submit an essay in high
school it happened so i used to like uh
i had this website that like would give
you free essays and i would use them all
the time uh you know and like most well
i don't know most people do it but you
know a lot of people do it some people
out there will think this is okay a
person
uh and
a person did it and it it was awesome
and i you like rewrite it a little bit
but then they came up with turnitin.com
which ended up becoming like a huge
company and sold for billions of dollars
i believe where you would turn in your
paper essay but then you also to submit
a an electronic copy and it did a pretty
good job of finding out if it was
plagiarized frankly i have no idea how
it did it and i don't actually think
it's that sophisticated of technology
but they just sold to schools and they
like trusted that it was legitimate
because like if you just google a phrase
in quotations you could see like where
you know i mean it's like not like that
sophisticated of a thing but like it
would alert teachers like okay like 98
of this is copied from somewhere else
right
but yeah
the teacher doesn't want to like google
the teacher doesn't want to google
everybody's thing so yeah that makes
that makes total sense and that's that's
exactly the case i think you're going to
have the creation of stuff of content on
the ai
auto-generated content and then you're
going to have the
fact checking side the detection
businesses also both are going to boom
you're going to have things that take a
video and say is this a deep fake or is
this a real video you're gonna have
another one that's like is this a
auto-generated content or does a human
write this like it's like the opposite
of captcha you know when you go to a
website and it says prove that you're a
human
it's gonna basically be like prove this
isn't a robot is basically what you're
going to have to do in order to trust
that this person actually like did the
work that's required for this um
so i think that that's going to be like
on both sides there's going to be
businesses i'll give you another area
that's going to get totally disrupted
um print and patterns so people talk
about like using ai for stock photos
using ai for like be like auto generated
music that's all going to happen too but
here's what i think is like more more
low-key like when when
patrick came on he was talking about
quilt businesses
so there's a huge market of just pattern
making so this is for all like clothing
you know uh blankets you know curtains
whatever basically
patterns and prints are everywhere uh
you know in apparel and fashion
and so if you want to go and actually
like make
clothing you will often use like
websites that have large libraries of
patterns and prints what happens is
today somebody hand draws each one of
those like oh this floral pattern or
this uh you know repeating pattern of
you know whatever it could be like fire
trucks for like you know some kid thing
or whatever
and
then that person gets paid when you go
buy that
buy that pattern you buy it for whatever
100 and now they get that as their like
royalty stream
well
this is all going to go ai in my opinion
somebody can compete with these because
the sites that do this they're worth
hundreds of millions of dollars these
marketplaces that have the creators and
they have the servers yeah we talked
about one of them i forget what it was
called
i think i think it had gotten acquired
by tv for like 400 million yeah flower
something yeah it's not some flowers
flower classic or something
they um
uh what that's going to turn into is i'm
going to go on there i'm going to be
like cool i'm making a um
you know a galaxy
i want a galaxy themed repeating pattern
so i'm just going to write galaxy themed
repeating pattern and it's going to
generate
galaxy themed patterns and then they
will be able to charge
one tenth of what the other sites do
because there's no human involved and
they'll just keep all of that revenue
for themselves so they will become
the supply side of the market so this is
like you can build a billion dollar
marketplace because you now don't have
to worry about supply it's what uber's
trying to do with self-driving cars
right it's like hey
we can make these rides way cheaper and
we can like you know make this whole
system more efficient we just got to get
to self-driving and tesla's trying to do
the same with the robo taxi it's like
the big idea in in transportation is
getting rid of the driver the same thing
is going to be the case with artists
it's like we're going to get rid of the
artists we're going to not need somebody
to do the photography the videography
the music the pattern making um you know
the voice over work that's what unreal
speeches right it's voiceover work um
the the the essay writing the 99 designs
every single one of those they're either
gonna have to release this and kill
their own supply side or someone is
going to come and do it and eat their
lunch i think this is one of the
multi-billion dollar trends that like
you could be on right now and i don't
say that for hyperbole like literally
this is the window the tech is just now
finally good enough it's not quite there
but you need to start now and you can
disrupt all of these marketplaces do you
ever recognize stock image models on
different websites
yeah there's this guy who's in the
bachelor who's a stock image uh and he's
like in like a bunch of like funny like
whatever random like kids halloween
costumes it's like there's that guy and
you see him again on this like uh hot
sauce commercial like there's that guy
and he's like this generic smiling black
guy
and uh it's like they just reuse him
everywhere i saw like the lady that was
on the google analytics page it was two
ladies and i saw one of them in public
and i went up and got a picture with her
and uh and like i saw her and i
recognized her and then there's this
other lady that was on the google
analytics page she's it's like it's
always it's like a lot of times the same
person uh it's like a racially ambiguous
woman with like curly hair it's like you
know it could be italian she could be
black she could be jewish why who knows
like it just represents everyone and i
see this woman everywhere on all
different websites i used her a couple
times i love this lady and i get sick of
using the same pictures though all the
time so for some of my projects i've
been using if you you can use dolly and
you can use a couple other services and
they'll give you fake people so i have a
couple websites that have like
testimonials and they're real
testimonials but i don't want to use the
people's uh face because i didn't
exactly ask them for it was like a email
that they like wrote me you know what i
mean i didn't want to use like their
face because they didn't give me
permission but like it's who cares just
a sentence
i can use that and i'll use
i google ai sample faces and you can get
all types of faces and you can say like
make this person this race make this
person happy make them serious you can
change it and you can make them all
types of stuff and i've been using that
for sample images because when we were
running the hustle every once in a while
we would like do it the right way where
we would like use an image that was for
commercial use but sometimes it would
get categorized wrong and we would we'd
get like what do they call it like a uh
i forget what it is
yeah that's right and they say like you
know we're you have to in multiple times
we've had to pay five grand you know
you're just like oh [__] these guys like
they're gonna cause an issue we just
gotta pay them five thousand dollars and
they're gonna go away but this is we
just we're gonna get uh you know we're
getting screwed here but whatever we
gotta do it so i've been using them for
stock images so i don't have to uh worry
about getting sued or get one of these
cease and desist letters
totally it's gonna be the case with um
stock images you know like designers
always use these libraries of like icons
and illustrations and there's like
websites like the noun project and other
things like that
what so what dolly did was basically
they just read all of the text on the
internet
and then they used it to create new
stuff and some people are like dude
that's messed up like github is doing
this too github basically read all of
the code that was on github they had a
crawler basically index all of that
learned they fed all of that that user
data and they you fed it into machine
learning and now they have this thing
called github copilot which is i think
like
i don't know how much it is like 100 a
month or something like that but it
basically is like you know if you're a
programmer we will this github codepilot
can basically help you write your code
you're like typing your code and it'll
just autofill like autocomplete
the line of code so it's like oh dude
that makes a
you know this 250 000 a year software
developer
more efficient and more effective and
less bugs and less mistakes and less
thinking uh it lets a less talented
person sort of create these functions
and write code and it's like a
no-brainer like github co-pilot is going
to generate like hundreds of millions of
dollars for github
create this product flip to switch it's
going to be a multi-billion dollar
product line just because it's
generating so much revenue wow and some
people are mad about it because they're
like dude
you read my code you use my code as the
training data and i get nothing from
this like that's crazy you're gonna
basically put me out of a job by using
my own data
as the training data for this and that's
the same thing that's gonna happen what
these like these websites by the way ben
found spoonflower what's the name of the
spoon flour so all you have to do if
you're doing this is like you're going
to go and you're going to scrape and
crawl spoonflower you're going to ingest
all of the
patterns with all of the tags and then
you're going to basically train it train
a data set so that it says okay cool
this is what a pattern with x y and z
keyword looks like great now you give me
that keyword again i can generate 500
new patterns from scratch
and spoonflower is basically going to
create its destroyer in that sense like
it is gonna the data from these from
stuff that's already on the internet is
what's gonna destroy those those
services and i say it kind of hype like
you know in a violent way like destroy
and all that stuff
but it is true like these are gonna be
very competitive very quickly and it's
going to be like the same way that
the chess programs like got really good
really fast and all of a sudden it's
like oh yeah a human cannot be gonna be
like
the gang of graphic design
yeah
exactly like this is going to enslave
and pillage you know it's going to go to
your village it's going to kill the men
it's going to marry all the women and
it's going to put the children to work
like that's what's going to happen with
this these ai marketplaces that's my my
prediction so ben go to this website i
sent you the chat can you share this uh
sam i think you've used this before too
but it's a cool one for people who don't
know
um it's this person does not exist yes
that's what i used
and so like look at this now it looks
like you bed kind of it just looks like
a basic white dude
this guy this looks like a mug shot
it takes a quick picture of you from
your web camera to just make someone
like you um this is a dude that this
person does not exist that's an ai
composite of a face so you can use this
face anywhere on your website copyright
free because
nobody's going to be like hey dude
that's me
um
this is like such a useful funny website
and it shows you in the bottom right
it'll tell you exactly how the image was
created it's like it was imagined by a
gan which is a type of machine learning
thing or whatever um here's how it works
you can use it yourself yeah blah blah
and watch this you can use it for cats
and horses and chemicals it's like this
camp this cat does not exist and you can
like click a cat and it'll like ai
generate a cat yeah this is amazing i
usually just take screenshot of those
and i use those on like different
websites
and so uh so yeah those are three three
ideas i think i said student essay
generation uh unreal voices for
voiceovers voice-overs
and never you know never having to
basically turning your voice into a
programmable asset and then patterns and
prints and that's just like that's not
even saying some of the obvious ones
that i met the other ones i mentioned
like stocks this is great
[Applause]
[Music]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool
a billion dollars
[Music]
all right i have something for you have
you heard of john steinberg
is he the guy who did cheddar yeah so
listen to this story and and i'm gonna
there's a reason why i'm telling you but
let me tell you the story so basically
john steinberg was the ceo of buzzfeed
for a long time i think when he joined
buzzfeed it was like 20 people so he
wasn't quite the co-founder but he was
he worked his way up to be ceo and he
was like the ad sales guy he became ceo
and he kind of was like pushing it hard
and it was almost like a co-founder of
buzzfeed
and he's incredibly aggressive
very aggressive and he started this
thing years ago like eight years ago or
maybe six years ago called cheddar and
the whole shtick was that it was going
to be a live tv station for facebook
live
and when he launched it we were just
getting started and he like messaged me
he goes have we met yet which was just
an alpha like just such an alpha way to
like
hey i forgot your name
yeah he was like hey dave i was like
dude it's uh it says samurai we're on
facebook you i know you're sorry about
it you're bad with names and faces
yeah what
he goes have we met yet we should meet
that's what he said and i go okay cool
he goes i'm in san francisco what's your
office i'll come tomorrow that's what he
said and i was like all right
yeah so
i hang out with them
nice nice guy incredibly aggressive
basically told me
that like buzzfeed was great but he
wanted to sell or something or i don't
know if he said this or i read about it
but like he wanted an exit and it didn't
happen so like he was like i'm just
gonna build this thing
and i'm gonna have an exit and he's told
me he goes what's gonna happen is i'm
gonna raise a little bit of money like
30 million dollars um it's going to do
pretty good and then a big cable company
is going to buy us because it's just
going to be cheaper for them to buy us
and to go make one of these cable uh
like like a 24-hour news network on
their own and they're going to buy us
for like 200 or 300 million dollars and
at the time and even at the time they
got bought no one watched this thing
you'd go into the facebook live and like
there'd be like 20 people watching at
any given point it was all on facebook
and like no one watched it
and i remember thinking like this guy's
crazy this is not going to work no one
wants this is this is nonsense this is a
bad business this is a bad company and
two years in he told me he goes in year
two or three we're gonna get acquired
for a couple hundred million bucks in
year three i think he sold the business
for 250 million dollars 100 percent
called his shot if you google cheddar
company
to a cable company to like an australian
cable company that i never heard of i
think they're popular in new york i
think they have like a thing in new york
too and he sold it and he totally pulled
it off and he completely disappeared he
fell off the map before he was like
speaking at all these conferences but he
called this shot and he nailed it and i
remember talking to other guys who
worked in the media industry and they're
like yeah he told me the exact same
thing
and he absolutely called this shot and
this guy is so aggressive man he's a
shark not in a bad way but like he just
bulldozed through this it just puts so
much intensity and energy and he pulled
it off but the reason i'm bringing this
up
he did it and another woman who we're
friends with rebecca did i asked her how
she got popular on youtube she was like
well i just quit my job and i like
worked 50 hours a week and i had like i
got up at nine and i like worked till
seven and like i studied the data and i
just treated it like a business and it
like became popular now i make you know
seven or eight figures whatever she
makes a year and i'm rich and famous and
whatever it worked because i was
talented and i worked hard and i treated
like a job
what i think is going to happen
and we this is a little circle jerky
because both you and i like twitter i
think that very few people take twitter
seriously enough to do that you know
like five or eight years ago we'd be
like mr beast you're gonna like dedicate
your life to youtube that's the
stupidest thing ever that won't work
like what are you doing this is just a
hobby this is a joke now it's not it's
not funny like we all know that like
that's real you can become a youtuber
and you know you could be like mr peace
and make hundreds of millions of dollars
a year you become a tick tocker and
become like some of these other famous
people and do all this crazy stuff no
one takes that seriously about twitter
where they think like well you know if
you just like quit and like take this
seriously and like build a following and
like write interesting stuff and i think
in the next two or three years we might
see like a few empires be built on top
of twitter and it sounds kind of silly
now because like oh it's just these like
stupid like you know twitter threads of
guys talking about x y and z and
summarizing wikipedia and they're kind
of right but i think that there's going
to be someone on twitter that treats it
kind of like cheddar did it's kind of
like mr beast and they take it really
seriously and i think there's actually a
huge opening and a huge gap in the
market right now where very few people
are taking it seriously and it's
incredibly easy to capitalize on this
second right now
this is one of the more interesting
things i feel like you said this is i
actually i don't even think you normally
think like this i feel like this is a
like uh
this is not your you say a lot of
interesting stuff but it's you you
usually fall into
i found this really interesting diamond
in the rough you're amazing at that
another is
i see what these people are doing and
let me break it down in simple terms
like all they're doing is x
and sometimes you're like uh you know
this is a trend or an industry i see
this is different this is like
this is something it's not the
difference i like i like that you're
bringing this up let's break this down
so
every degree with me
at first when you i think you tweeted
this out and i was like i don't really
understand what he's talking i didn't
really understand it
uh
then you just explained it and it's i'm
starting to come around on it i'm like
oh wait he's kind of right every
big social media platform has like
native stars so yes if you're uh you
know whatever you're
the president and you go on twitter
you're gonna get a bunch of followers
that's one thing but basically if you
take every medium so podcasting you have
joe rogan you have like then the people
like joe rogan you have to call her
daddy's and you have like other tim
ferriss you have other people who like
they become stars on that platform and
they use that to build a
pretty big empire you know
tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions that they can make of it
youtube obviously there's youtubers tick
tock has tick tock stars people who were
not famous on youtube but got famous on
tick tock
instagram also right there's instagram
models and instagram like influencers
that
they were nobody and they became big on
instagram multi-billion dollar companies
you know kardashians rihanna like these
like huge things
well i think they rihanna kardashians
they were big off of instagram they were
very big without it like instagram also
and instagram add turbocharged to them
but like there are other people that are
you know um just instagram like
instagram made them famous like dan
bilzerian is a good example right like
he's not famous without instagram then
with instagram he becomes famous and
then now he does multiple platforms
right but by the end everybody does
multiple platforms but
you kind of you're really good at the
medium so like for example dan buzarian
takes photos of himself blowing up cars
with hot girls making bikinis guess what
instagram is a visual
like you know put one killer image on
there and they're amazing at it and so
uh that worked really well there
you're kind of right who is that on
twitter who is
who is a twitter native star i don't
even know what that would be like is
there somebody who's there i mean
there's a there's a few like i would say
like and i'm on twitter 10 times a day
like how do i not know this like you and
i are like very miniature versions but
we haven't really like i'm talking like
sahil's a bigger version so our friend
sahil bloom trung who used to work for
me he is kind of like that but you know
we're still talking like 500 000
followers no one has really pushed it to
where it's like how do i get 10 or 20
million you know how do i become like
how do i build a proper empire as
opposed to a niche now the difference is
uh basically between everything you
mentioned and twitter is twitter is
copy-based text-based whereas the other
ones are visual based so i think there's
one of two routes that's going to happen
you figure out how to add visuals to
your thing and
videos don't usually do that well on
twitter but pictures do or you just get
really good at writing and i was like
well writing's at that port but i'm like
wait no i'm an idiot like you know who
danielle steele or james patterson is
yeah yeah yeah these people have sold
literally like i believe danielle steele
has sold like a hundred million plus
books i don't know if you know this but
in san francisco she's got like the
biggest mansion in the baddest house
yeah billionaires row
her house is like the big fortress yeah
and then you got james patterson i bet
you he's a billionaire too james
patterson basically writes like 50 books
a year i don't even know if he writes a
lot of them if he just smacks his logo
on it but like
you know i was thinking like well here
that sounds outrageous but okay
uh i i forget but it's maybe one week
it's like one a month it'll say like you
know um what he does is like it'll be
like uh written by james patterson and
bill clinton and then it says like
and also this other name and it's like a
duo about them it's like a story written
about like the white house or something
like that and he like partners it's like
this weird thing that he does
he he writes a ton he's prolific and a
lot of like like real quote authors like
these like artists folks are like oh
that's just garbage but he's like dude i
don't care i'm pumping this [__] out
anyway
authors like definitely crush it still
and the power of the written word is
very powerful enough to like you know
get these people to buy all these books
and i still think that's possible but i
i do think that we're gonna see like an
empire built on top of twitter arguably
you and i have
created we've easily created uh seven
figures of personal
income through twitter
maybe you could say even i would have to
add it up maybe eight figures but a lot
uh i think though that there's gonna be
literally billionaires created on
twitter and it hasn't happened yet
though
wow uh
yeah what's we can't call ours empires
like what's what's a very very small
like a lego like a convenience store
yeah like we we've played like a quickie
mart uh yeah we own like four burger
kings
you want to me and you're right that
sahil and trung are good examples of
like they
actually try
so like they like
religiously write content they schedule
it they research it they like publish
they like try to amplify it they have
called action at the bottom and it works
and i've seen them crawl from zero to
stop hills at like half a million maybe
more i don't know uh
a lot of people don't even know that
trung so trunk worked at the hustle he
wrote the daily email we found him when
he was working at like a as a financial
analyst not like it was all internal
reports we like he signed up for twitter
while he worked at my company and we all
like shared each other in this like
silly circle jerk circle and now he's
got 600 000 followers and he's like a
personality and like people know him
like they talk about him and how he's
funny and all this stuff and i think
it's gonna happen and like when i
tweeted out that event thing a thousand
people signed up and i'm like
oh my god like why aren't you actually
see instagram like you'll see like the
logan
the jake pauls and logan paul they'll
like say like i'm gonna be when they're
starting on youtube they're like we're
gonna be at this location come and they
film all these crazy videos of all these
people around us no one's doing that
[__] for twitter and
i think that someone needs to just take
the youtuber playbook and just deploy it
here and take it full time and seriously
and they could create tens or hundreds
of millions of dollars of wealth and so
what would you do because like i think
well the guys we talked about they you
know sahil basically does
like kind of like mental model
intellectual like stuff or it's like oh
you know either like kind of what i'll
call like the generic life advice
generic business advice or like
um
you know hey let me tell you about this
phenomenon in psychology about cognitive
biases and here's 30 cognitive biases
you you want to be aware of and like i
don't know why these do so well they do
incredibly well uh that's not my cup of
tea but it's definitely other people's
cup of tea for that here's what they
need to do here's how you cross the
chasm here's how you cross this
threshold so basically these guys are
popular on this twitter medium and
twitter is a it feels like a one to one
a little bit or maybe like a one to ten
it's like me and my ten friends like
consume this and we'll joke about it but
i'm not talking to a guy on the train or
i'm not like telling a family member
like hey uh you know did you guys see x
y and z like we're not talking about
that so what they need to do is two
things number one they need to meet up
with like mainstream celebrity people or
like mainstream people and take pictures
with them and show it and it's like oh
man this guy's like bigger than just my
little audience look at this like these
people like arnold schwarzenegger likes
this person and took a photo with them
that's amazing the second thing that
they need to do is they need to get off
of twitter and into real life so for
example in the early 2010s when the
caspers of the world were coming out
uh subways in manhattan were underpriced
for the billboards and a couple of these
companies like subway oscar they go
let's advertise on these billboards down
in the subway and then we'll actually
buy real billboards and people are like
why would you do that like we could
track all this on the internet and
they're like well because if we get it
out off the internet it's going to seem
more than just an online thing and it's
going to feel more like a real tangible
thing you know you're going to see like
this ad next to like uh you know a ford
ad and next to this thing it's going to
feel like this is actually a little bit
more legitimate and so what they need to
figure out is how to do that so you do
that by having real life events you do
that by like getting a book that you
publish you get that by getting a cameo
on a tv show and you like get everyone
in on the joke it's like hey everyone
check this out uh they asked me to be a
background on friends like here look you
can see my head in that hilarious like
you do these things like that where it's
like real life and like bigger than just
this one to ten thing and then people
start taking you seriously and realize
that it creates fomo and it creates um
social proof and you start becoming
actually culturally relevant you know
what i mean and that's how you should do
it so you just like take pictures with
you and celebrities and then try to uh
get in more in-person stuff so you're
off the internet and i think that would
work
yeah i think i think that's good advice
like uh
people will
believe about you what you believe about
yourself and um and also people will
believe about you what they think others
believe about you so if i see you
hanging out you know if i see that's why
youtube works right like people on
youtube will have like you know or
instagram they'll have like they're
taking a picture but it's actually the
background that's the picture it's like
i'm just trying to show you that i'm
sitting in this car or at this place or
with these people and um
there's like
everything that's said is actually in
the background the foreground is just
kind of like your excuse to say it or
when casey neistat's like walking
through new york and he has kids coming
up to him he goes hey what's up kid say
hi to the you're on the vlog like you
know what i mean it's like oh wow like
in new york casey gets recognized
everywhere he's more than just what i
see on my screen
and like celebrities do this they like
when they like tip off you know the
paparazzi to come like take pictures of
them and they're like they like pretend
like they're trying to not be seen but
then like they actually it's like a deal
like hey dude i'm going to be here come
on come show up and take my photo and
then we're going to use that photo for
this or they'll like you know
do stuff like that so so i think that's
a thing like i had a buddy who created a
he's got like an online e-commerce brand
they open up their first store the
store's not gonna do that many sales but
just
showing that hey we opened our first
store in new york it's like kind of like
you know wherever in new york some like
small place and it's like just that
makes it feel like this brand is more
trustworthy it's more established it's
more legit and then they had a bunch of
friends like 15 friends show up and they
were like doing a rubbing uh ribbon
cutting ceremony and the friends are all
like hey well yeah hey question for you
like you know like trying to pretend
like they're the media and um
and
and like if you zoomed out it's like 10
people standing in a small arrester but
like from the right angle it looked like
a mob was at the store and again it's
like this perception creates some
version of reality so i definitely think
that helps i don't think that's enough
to build the empire i think you got to
do two things one
be in it for like the next seven years
like mr beast all these guys they didn't
start with like you know as big as they
are it takes like five to seven years to
build something like really truly
massive the second is i would stop
trying to jump off twitter and go to
other places and be like
this is where the good [__] is i'm going
to master this medium and this medium
totally i'm going to make it work here
the third is i would do some of the
stuff that just helps build fame in the
first place so
um
i think having your lane or your niche
helps because it'll attract people who
are interested in that second
controversy or collabing with others i
think it's going to work you know and
people don't do controversial stuff
really on twitter right now but it
should be like oh my god i called in to
like this show and i got you know how
people used to call into howard stern
and like get him to like say this crazy
[__] like check this out got him you
know what i mean
well some people do it that uh and it
works like there's a guy who's doing
this with zach weinberg or something
like that yeah he literally loved that
guy built and sold like i don't know a
two billion dollar company in like the
biotech space or some [__] like that
but why does everybody know him because
he's the guy who just will consistently
[__] on crypto he just is challenging
people to fight about crypto and he's
just trying to debate them in public and
embarrass them that is this whole shtick
and he's getting so much fame for
dunking on people in crypto and um
because there's a set of audience that
likes to a watch a fight and b that
likes to that is anti-crypt that has
some anti-crypto feelings and they're
like he is their champion you go debate
people because i don't know if i would
be able to and so that's that's exactly
how shapiro got famous too by the way
and on top of that then you have like
keith or boy or whatever people who are
just like a dick to other people like
he'll just like respond to somebody like
wrong
and they're like well explain like you
know i'd love to hear your perspective
and he's like i don't share my
perspective with [__] losers
like he's like he'll like he'll [__] on
you once and then he'll even if you try
in good faith to come back he'll be like
the data is out there go read a book and
yeah one time he was like one time the
best thing goes i've forgotten more
about startups and you'll ever even know
yeah exactly or he'll be like call me
after your sixth unicorn because that's
where i am or whatever you know like he
he's like you know obnoxiously just like
[__] on people and it's hilarious
and because of that like the controversy
spread some people hate him some people
love him and uh he kind of uses that to
to
to grow so anyways i think controversy
is also another underrated thing there's
a bunch of things that people need to do
but i would say the main one
is like find your your angle your hook
your niche like for casey neistat it's
the daily vlog for other people it's the
explainer videos it's like whatever you
gotta find that for you on twitter and
then like do it for five to seven years
and have faith that like just like it
wasn't obvious that being a youtuber was
just such a big deal back then
i think it's not that obvious
you know to your point that you could do
this on twitter too
yeah i uh so that's my that's my i'm
that's my pitch i think it could be cool
all right can i tell you
about something that i kind of knew
about but has recently blown my mind
yeah it's the teal fellowship so you
know that's amazing what the teal
fellowship is ben i'm curious do you
know what the teal fellowship has come
come off from you for a bit cause i
think sam already knows i want to talk
somebody who's maybe more where the
audience is which may you know aware but
not familiar
yeah so i know the teal fellowship is
i'll tell you just my impression of
someone who doesn't know a ton about it
it's just that it's for
essentially high schoolers who are super
geniuses and peter thiel is going to
give you a bunch of money in order to
not go to college and do something cool
instead
uh kind of you're in it's actually i
think it's actually for people in
college to leave college for a year so
100k to basically leave college for a
year and work on something interesting
and uh ben if i asked you like hey is it
like successful unsuccessful do you have
any idea
um
no except for that i know um
uh what's his name did it uh
the guy who did ethereum vitalik yeah
exactly metallic yeah yeah so
by the way i still haven't told my
vitalik story on air which is i was in
amsterdam and i saw him and i couldn't
think what to say and he's walking right
past me and i just turned and went
you're vitalik
and he didn't like look or say anything
he just kept walking but it was him
did he have security with him
no he was walking all alone on the
streets of amsterdam
at 8 am in the morning it's just us
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot
grow better
yeah we need to protect this man he
never has security with him and he's
just like wanders around to random cafes
and goes to events and stuff like this
i'm like dude
yeah i really hope he's got such good
security that he just can't see them
i'll that's what i'll tell myself
um
so
this teal fellowship thing is amazing
the teal fellowship was exactly what you
said
uh peter thiel comes out peter thiel is
the kind of uh original founder of
paypal
he was the first investor in facebook
put 500k into facebook early on which
became hundreds of millions of dollars
not billions of dollars
and um
also a prolific investor and a bunch of
other things including spacex and other
businesses so peter thiel comes out and
he basically says
uh college education is a bubble
he says um college education is sort of
a joke he's like you know
it hides under this this this like
banner like it's teaching you something
like you're getting information but
really what you're getting is some
version of like an insurance policy like
i got this degree so i'm not going to
fall through the cracks of society and
you're getting like you know some status
symbol like i got this stamp on my thing
so it's like a luxury it's like a luxury
product like wearing a nice bag your
harvard degree is like your louis
vuitton bag
and uh and so he talks about college and
he's like it's costs just keep going up
and up and up but the value and the the
salaries that you make don't go up um
and so it's this like overpriced bubble
just like the housing bubble he says and
he says i'm going to offer
um
i'm going to offer something called the
teal fellowship which is a hundred
thousand dollars if you drop out of
college and go work on something
interesting
and a bunch of people criticize them
they say
uh dude you know how dare you you're
telling kids like the normal phrase is
kids stay in school you're like
we get it you're contrarian you're
saying kids don't say and go stay in
school and you're like trying to get
people to drop out like what kind of
like
you're worse than a vape you know and so
uh you know people didn't like what he
was doing and other people were just
like oh it's cool but like you know who
knows if this is gonna work or not like
all right you're gonna pay this kid 100
grand to you know do a summer project
great so what
this thing is amazing it is producing it
worked out really well didn't it
and nobody talks about it so let me tell
you some of the things that have come
out of this um
you have like you said ethereum which is
like a 170 billion dollar market cap
thing that came from vitalik probably
like this generation's version of
facebook is like you know is ethereum so
that comes out of this where vitalik
does the teal fellowship and uh
continues you know working on ethereum
during that time and uh and he launches
so that's one super super super
successful thing also figma which is
like a somewhere between five and ten
billion dollars closer to company
that takes on adobe in the design space
and uh
dylan who is you know the founder of
figma was in the was in the teal
fellowship
uh another one oyo rooms so this is in
india it's like a um
you know kind of like a airbnb-ish sort
of thing it's like a hospitality uh you
know website oh your rooms multi-billion
dollar company tens of billions
luminar technologies um most people
don't know this it's a like lidar
company that basically uh the technology
you need for self-driving cars and this
thing i think went public in a spac this
guy's like i don't know
21 22 years old 23 years old something
like that and he's worth like a billion
dollars he's like one of the world's
youngest billionaires if not the
youngest billionaire off of this thing
um that is just alone is crazy also
polka dot another crypto protocol valued
at you know seven billion dollars
um like i just told you basically 200
billion dollars worth of business value
that has come from this program and it's
but then there's way more
there's actually like a uh dozens that
are in like the hundred million dollar
range i invested in a company that
recently raised another round i think it
was owner.com the guy adam he uh he was
a teal fellow and i believe i mean that
that that potentially could be a unicorn
but it's hundreds of millions for sure
uh and there's like dozens more like
that the reason i got reminded of this
was because i invest in italic and
jeremy kai is the founder of italian and
he was like
oh yeah i was a teal fellow that's how i
i was like how did we meet eventually
he's like oh yeah i was a teal fellow we
came to your office and you gave a talk
and i thought it was awesome and so
that's why we kept in touch and i was
like dude was it vitalik in the room
he's like i don't think he's like i
don't think he was at that event but
he's like dude he used to like crash on
our couch like you know he was part of
the program and
he's like he's i was like what was he
like he's like he's genuinely the
weirdest person ever like the weirdest
person i've ever met and like he's like
yeah in a good way in a bad way nothing
like he's just nothing like nothing like
i've ever seen just a different
different sort of cat and
i was like this is this is too good
i think i think you should uh keep using
the word cat by the way
you like how i did that i've been yeah
i'm workshopping right now yeah it looks
good on you
yeah i take it out for a spin i take it
out of the garage you know you know
twice a week and i just see do people
kind of like flinch when i say that you
know um it was a good flinch
tried it with lit and that was i had to
put that one back in storage no you're
not coming back out i put that one on
ebay actually got rid of it
yeah no you're yeah you're you're you're
too much of a grey bush for that one but
cat yeah cat was cool i would stick with
cat but it is crazy man this the peter
thiel i thought at first it was real uh
it was kind of stupid i'm like dude this
is weird like one of these like little
18 year old nerds like they're not gonna
do anything interesting obviously i was
wrong um yeah like
when i when i was
like rethinking my opinion on it i was
like wow i guess just like
high iq matters like these guys they're
just
they have more power than i do i i
always say they're just they're high
you're higher functioning than me you
know that's just the only way i can
describe it you have more horsepower
your oven burns hotter and it actually
it it it truly matters and it makes a
difference
your oven burns hotter it's so good
oh god i love that
you know what i mean they just got that
they got that that
heater furnace that's how i felt
when i was at twitch i was like uh i was
like okay let's see what are the like
you know i had kind of had opinions from
the outside like okay at these big tech
companies what are the people like what
are the exact like what are the average
people like you know how hard do they
work how smart are they like you know do
they have like all these processes that
are way better than the messy stuff i
was doing at my startup
and like you know for the most part i
would say it's kind of like you know i
walked out a little cockier than i came
in and i came in pretty cocky and that's
what i was you know just sort of like oh
okay like you know they don't have some
magic you know processes or the people
aren't that much better
except like two or three people at the
company one of which is emmett who's the
founder
you know
we would sit down and there would be
like you know data science would be
presenting some report on like
you know some trends and i'm just
sitting there trying to like it's a six
page memo
i'm trying to like stop yawning because
it's like i'm just like why do i keep
yawning i'm having this like you know
reflex and i'm reading this thing i'm
just trying to understand these charts
and like you just hear this little click
and it's like someone's pen is down
and it's like you you know if you're
taking a math that's like who's done
with the test already and it would be
emmet he'd be like pens down he'd be
playing hearthstone on his phone
and you're like no he like he must have
already read this or like anybody he
must just skim
and then then they're like all right
yeah we're ready to start the discussion
and he would be like so on page three
you know this chart actually i noticed
that the axis is a little wrong because
you know if this was true then well then
this other chart on page seven would
show this i'm like what the you know
what is happening how is your brain
processing this much information this
quickly and somehow always getting to
like
like the harder the issue it's like we
all spent our time and energy like
trying to parse out what's important
like he immediately got to what was
important and had the conclusion and had
like the follow-up question and also
identified why this piper wasn't very
good in the first place and once i saw
the brain doing that i was like oh okay
there's just
some cars you know have more horsepower
like or as you said the oven burns a
little hotter and like
his oven burns way hotter than mine and
i was like oh that's good to know like
because i have this thing i always say i
like to see what level 12 looks like
like
what is oh that speaker system's a
little too loud for me but like i want
to know what volume on 12 even is i want
to feel you know my own chest leader
like vibrating with the bass and it's
like okay i don't want to be somebody
who never sees it i want to see it
what was he like in like real life like
outside of work because have you ever
seen some of these people interact in
like normal like life like they like i
told you about one friend that's like
intense and he literally only owns a two
t-shirts one pair of underwear one pair
of socks and his laptop that's like the
only thing he owns so he's worth
hundreds of millions of dollars and then
like i know a bunch of these guys that
are like this and like for hobbies
they're just all in and like so if
they're into like uh you know like
[__] their body or something they've
got like every gadget you could ever
imagine in their they they could tell
you all about it and or if they're into
dieting they've got like their pants
like my friend jack he's in a uh
supplements he and he's got literally
thirty thousand dollars worth of
supplements in a closet and they'd be
like what's this dude what's this do
what's this do you just like test
everything
what was he like in uh like like was he
like if he's into cars could he like
tell you every single thing about like a
porsche and what year it was from and
why it was special
yeah yes but before i tell you about him
uh i just read this thing that was like
about sergey brin like the co-founder of
google and it's like oh what is sir like
you know cause he's in the news because
of the his wife and elon all that stuff
and some people like what is sergey
doing nowadays because he's not i don't
think he's at google anymore um
and it said over the last
year or two he's become
very into personal fitness in fact he
has been trying to master several
olympic sports i was like what
dude i don't know man i looked at this
guy what like what olympic sport
pig pong i don't know
yeah curling um yeah the other one is
they said he's currently writing a
physics textbook and i was like of
course he's writing a physics textbook
like that's more like come on yeah um so
anyways yeah these guys are wired like
that where like when they go in they go
in like very deep uh honestly i don't
know him super well because i interacted
mostly at work um and anytime it was
outside of work
it was
it was really cool but it was like you
know limited it wasn't like i hung out
with them like a hundred times it would
maybe be more like five times you know
something like that over the couple
years that i was there um what i would
say is like a couple of little things
that stood out one
he's like us he's an idea machine in
fact i need to get him on the podcast
because you've been saying that for
three years now
i know i know and when i was there i
didn't ask him because i was like uh you
know already you know me doing this
podcast is not you know yeah you're like
if you want to bail at noon and go and
record
yeah it's not everyone's favorite thing
i do um
you know
but but i think now i could do it um
but he would like he told me this idea
he's like i tell you about his gym idea
no
he's like he's like jim's he's like gyms
need to be uh made like video games if i
was gonna leave twitch i might start
this uh a gym that's structured like a
video game so he's like this is how it
works you show up and you're like at the
beginning character of a game like you
show up and we give you kind of like
your basic uniform and we have a little
little wrist strap that like tracks your
level of like fitness and intensity as
you work out
and you like basically level up and so
like every time you come to the gym
you're earning points and like as you
earn points like we give you like better
gear like we'll give you the like the
the more fitted you know clothes that
look cooler and so you can like visibly
see people's different levels as they go
to the gym you would be able to like go
into certain sections of the gym that
were previously locked to you you would
be able to get like protein shakes and
stuff for free and he's like uh he's
like i think if you gamify a gym people
would come more and like actually this
is kind of played out with peloton
peloton is very much organized like this
with leaderboards and stuff like that
gamification
but i was like this is a crazy idea he's
like yeah it'd be like the world of
warcraft of gyms like people would grind
like years of their life to level up
their character to 60 and they would
like work to do it he's like i think you
could do that with with a gym i was like
wow yeah i mean people do that with like
karate and jiu jitsu you know black belt
brown belt blue belt exactly and they
stick with it and they keep showing up
because they're 10 plus years and he's
like but you know you don't want the
increments to be like a year before you
see some progress like every time you
come you need to be earning a little bit
more and getting a little bit more
unlocked you know and see that the next
milestone is just within reach
um so i thought that was interesting the
second one he was like
uh
he was like trying to plug in the
computer to like screen share one time
with me like uh like normally these
meetings like set up by somebody else
but like if it's just youtube like hey
you gotta do it plug it in and he's like
these [__] cables he's like you know
honestly i think i could create like the
apple for like accessories for computer
accessories he's like just like the best
connecting cables the best cable
management the best plugs he's like he's
like nobody's like look at this it's
like every office in the world has these
and look at how bad they look how ugly
they are how poorly they function
how confusing they are he's like i think
you could just build like a really
nicely designed cables and connectors
and accessories company for every office
in the country and like you know people
would uh people would pay for it and i
was like
like why do you think of these things
like this is weird and so that's what
people say about you
he had a dozen ideas that were like this
what was there all right that's one
thing that i noticed
we'll wrap this up real quick but i um
there's this famous story so this guy
named chris sacco was a popular investor
and invested in uh instagram and a bunch
of other stuff in uber and he's supposed
to be one of the best angel investors of
all time he told this story somewhere
where he is in tahoe or truckee where he
has a home and he's with his dad and
travis kalanick right when he was about
to start uber came over
to just spend the weekend you know
family vacation and travis um and and
chris sack his dad mr saka they start
playing uh wii tennis
and travis is playing and the dad's
playing and they just like are being
casual and travis was like all right you
want to step it up so he steps it up and
he just crushes them and he just beats
this guy like
so bad and uh mr sack was like what the
hell man and travis goes i've got a
surprise to show you and he puts the wii
from his left hand into his right hand
he goes i was playing left-handed the
whole time i'm actually right-handed
let's really play and he goes
travis goes all right but i do have to
tell you something and they go to the
ratings board and he's number two in the
whole world at wii tennis and chris
sacca was like right then and there i
realized i never want to compete against
this guy because his drive and his hobby
is winning and he just proved that like
in his free time of starting this
company he's just going to be number one
in the world at wii tennis just cuz just
because he has to and he just hustled my
dad thinking that he was left-handed and
it worked perfectly this guy is a winner
and that's why chris sakaka said he
invested in his like i just see his
intensity and just walking around
dude 100 agree peter thiel same way he's
like a master or grand master at chess
and like the in the paypal mafia which
is now like the most successful
entrepreneur group ever uh i think
several of them were like
very very high level chess players um
that that have gone through that you
know that like we're in that thing
there's like something to the the oven
burns hotter that's like true for some
of these people it's a combination of
intensity and capability um that is that
is definitely true like
uh another kind of like observation that
i was like huh that's weird that doesn't
seem normal um so i guess two little
ones one was i was like what do you do
for fun like what do you when you hang
out like what are you doing he's like oh
like i love board games he's like you
should come over like a board game night
and i was like uh okay like what what
are we playing like you know monopoly
like twister what do we got going here
and he's like
because this is like that'd be like we
only play like deep strategy games and
it was like
we only play katan on like hard mode or
like even katan it's like the beginner
one you like name two other games i
don't even know about like you know are
like this the like the board games that
are like actually
you know like multi-level multi-hour
strategy games and basically it was him
and the brothers from stripe and like
the founder of reddit and they would
just get together and play these games
on the weekend that's what they did
that's exactly how i want them to spend
their time
exactly so i thought that was kind of
funny and then the the other one was
like um we were in a meeting and he we
were talking about like i don't know
like some policy like oh these you know
whatever
yes some girl streaming on twitch and
like her nipples showing like is that
okay but it's like you know she lives in
denmark you know
what are the rules around this should we
ban her or like what and
and so there was always these policy
questions coming up over and over and
over again and it felt like you can't
win because whatever twitch did it was
like oh dude they're trying to control
us censor us like they're inconsistent
they should have also changed it over
here like it was a no-win policy
and then you know like he would he would
have these like
he would have these hobbies which is
like reading like old books that nobody
would read like no normal person is
reading these books and then he'd be
able to connect the dots on two like
completely unrelated things it's sort of
like ben's podcast stuff where it's like
oh actually like you know the
rothschilds similarly set this up in a
you know set up their will in a weird
way because of this maybe you should do
this like dude how do you know all this
like really specific stuff from history
he would be like
do you know how the potato farmers
govern their like you know farms in the
netherlands during the potato drought
and then like the head of policy is like
no just tell me what he's like actually
they created this governing council that
was blah blah blah and like the cool
thing about this rule of law was well
maybe we should you know you should read
that like tell me what you think about
it and they're like all right like where
do i find this like out of print book
that you read like randomly and you
remember what the potato farmers did and
so he would always bring these like
really unrelated examples in
um that was one thing and the other one
was
you he would debate you over semantics
like to death so you would be like um
you know like it'd be like an exec
offside he'd be like and some people
like you know i just feel like we don't
want enough like trust on the team and
everyone's like nodding like yeah you
know like you know he's like
collaboration is a problem or whatever
and he'd be like well is it trust or
collaboration because trust means this
and collaboration means this like well
you know just like the general like
trust collaboration just working
together better he's like but like again
define for me what you mean when you say
trust i just want to make sure i have it
right and he's not trying to like it's
not a gotcha he wants he's like a hyper
literal person so he's like when you say
it's failing i take that to mean it's
failing is it failing or is it this
other thing and people are like just
getting lost in the sauce of this like
semantical debate
um but like he really wanted to be hyper
literal about it and i've never seen
anybody do this in a you know there were
upside that became a bad example here
but like i think you understand the
general premise which is that he really
cared about words what they mean and why
we're using them and if we're using them
correctly to describe what's going on
and everybody else was kind of hand-wavy
about stuff especially like the higher
you go up an organization you sort of
get paid for being sort of high hand
wavy like a politician and he was the
opposite of that so these were some of
the things i noticed that now when i
invest in founders i'm like
like invested this guy who created
something called ski-o and he's like
yeah i'm just like i was like what'd you
do before this he's like oh it's a
professional call of duty player like
before that i was you know i was like
grinding in world of warcraft like uh it
was a waste of time but like yeah i was
you know top three in the world or
whatever it's like what uh oh you were
like a top three starcraft player like
you know in this on the on the east
coast server like okay you're a winner
and you're obsessive and you are like
you find the rules of the game and then
you like optimize to win it and sure
enough now like with his thing he's like
a wrecking ball with like acquiring
customers because he just find this is
the new game and he's like finding rules
and he's like maximizing his edge in
everything that he can do to the point
where he's kind of like a nut job uh
dude but like you know it works
at the end of episodes like this i'm
exhausted
i feel like i just exerted so much
energy both listening and speaking do
you have to take a nap at the end of
this because you just spoke like with
incredibly high energy for we've done
this for we're an hour and 17 minutes in
do you get exhausted i i take naps after
no not at all i uh i leave these on a
high
um so do i but then i need to go to
always
you well yeah you never have water i
usually drink three drinks while i'm i'm
doing these but like i'm exhausted i get
exhausted just listening
well that's probably my fault so i'm
sorry
no no
it's a good exhausted i'm like god i
just learned so much and i need to get
so much better at this this and this by
hearing this story and i was just so
intensely listening and enthralled by
this conversation that i need a nap i've
got to go lay down i gotta go rest
balogie went on tim ferriss's podcast
and did like a three-hour podcast and i
listened to it last night and like
literally while it was happening i could
feel my brain fatiguing just trying to
like digest what this man was saying
he's so sp and by the way you also hear
tim tim ferriss sound i loved him first
tim ferriss sounds like an absolutely
defeated man on these podcasts with
biology because biology would be like um
anarcho you know on one hand you have
the world capitalist on the other hand
you have the anarcho uh anarch the
anarcho-capitalist do you know what i
mean when i say that and tim's like no
tell me and like that happens 40 times
in the episode he's like um are you
familiar with the concept of the you
know the schrodinger window it tim's
like um no but i assume you can tell me
and he's like he just does that over and
over and over dude one time when he was
with us he was like he was like you know
bitcoin is kind of like battle of the
bulge and you remember how the germans
were doing i'm like dude i don't i
needed an analogy for your analogy like
you don't please don't reference battle
of the bulge would try to explain a
complicated topic like right now i was
like you know bitcoin's kind of like uh
like neuroscience like you know how like
the chemicals of like this this and this
interact this way think about the big
bitcoin is the amygdala of the crypto
ecosystem
dude i don't know
yeah that's what was happening and uh i
guess i did that to you in this case but
no you're you're well you're way dumber
i could totally keep up with that it
just was a good story
you just talked more
no i thought it was good that was a
compliment i get exhausted because i'm
like so into it like i like i i i love
hearing these stories so much
we used to do these mastermind like
dinners or hangouts where it'd be me sam
and like three other guys and we'd meet
up every two weeks or three weeks
something like that
and it would always be like you know
each person gets 20 minutes and you sort
of say what's going on in your business
what's working what and what you want
help what you want the other guys to
like you know basically help you think
through and then
and those things last basically if you
just do the math it's like six people 20
minutes each but everybody runs 10
minutes over and like you know we start
10 minutes late it's like this thing is
three hours long and we would always
start it after work so we'd started at
like seven
it would finish at 10 10 30. uh we
skipped dinner nobody's like gone to the
bathroom and
basically there was two reactions some
people were like [__] exhausted by
the end of this and they're like uh this
is great but like man next time let's
try to be a little shorter uh and like i
get that logically
my reaction and we used to do some of
these at your office i remember at the
hustle's office
i don't know if you noticed i would
leave your office at 10 10 30 and i
would go straight to my office and i
would just work for four or five
straight hours because i can't do that i
was so inspired i was like a combination
of inspired by the like your guys's
awesomeness
um
panicked that like oh my god i have so
much i need to do that i now realize
and like oh [__] i need to do all of
this and i'm just gonna try to do as
much as i can tonight uh and like i was
is a combination of like enthusiasm
and like feeling overwhelmed by like the
amount of potential and ideas and like
stuff i could be doing to make our stuff
grow more no i gotta go like
drink gatorade and take a power nap
yeah i need to fuel up i better go eat a
cliff bar
i get warm now i'm like my blood sugar's
low i can feel it
[Laughter]
i guess that's the episode right then
[Music]
you